bismillah alhamdulillah Salam alaikum
peace be with you thank you for tuning
in to the Deen show we're gonna be
talking about the difference between
judging someone and giving the loving
advice this week on the Deen show such
an important topic we will be covering
it with my next guest Sheikh Omar
Suleiman here on the Deen show don't go
anywhere we'll be right back
now you just said something Arabic
what'd you say I said Allah God willing
you said I said I will Aiko how are you
what does this mean peace be with you we
never it never gets old because the Deen
show is known for simplifying things
making it very simple for the people
because some people out there like why
these guys speak in Arabic Eddie you're
not Arab you're an American so we start
off with peace and you defined it Salaam
alaikum
tell us tell us now you you you've been
on Adi show before we're SD how's it
feel being back now on HD muscle ah you
look even better on see the alarm is
going off right now see we got this
alarm when every time you say something
in Arabic you said mashallah what is
this me mashallah means you know
admiring the creation of God uh-huh now
someone again there's a lot of not yet
Muslims out there and they're like okay
why don't you guys just say these things
in English why do you keep saying them
in Arabic how would you answer that it's
a habit that's one obviously and also
the Prophet peace be upon him used to
say these words
so we're emulating the Prophet peace be
upon him saying these words that's part
of our terminology now again someone
says okay what what prophet are you
talking about well Prophet Muhammad
peace be upon real short who was Prophet
Muhammad
apart from Muhammad peace be upon him
was the final messenger that was sent to
mankind mm-hm now when you accept
Mohammed is a Messenger how did Jesus
Moses neighbor how do they
fit in do you exclude them no absolutely
not in fact Allah says in the Quran that
to disbelieve in any one of the
messengers of God is to disbelieve in
all of them so is it safe to say as soon
as you accept Muhammad as the last right
away you accept all those that came
before him absolutely accept everything
that he brought with him so we brought
with him as well it was the confirmation
of the messengers that came before you
said someone in Arabic Allah people have
heard the probably a thousand times but
there's one person or a thousand out
there that tuned in for the first time
and they think okay Allah what is this
why don't you just say God who is Allah
who is Allah Allah is the god the the
one true God who sent these messengers
and prophets to call to the worship of
that one God the same God of Islam
Judaism Christianity all of the
religions that claim to believe in one
God the the God of Abraham peace be upon
him the God of Jesus peace be upon him
in the God of all of them is Islam a new
religion is it some something new that
came with Mohammed Aslam is a
continuation of the the same message of
submission and attainment of peace by
submitting yourself to God and
submitting your will to God and obeying
his commands so Islam is the religion of
God himself and is the religion of Adam
all the way peace be upon him to
Muhammad peace be upon him and until God
inherits this earth so it is the real it
is the religion of worship worshiping
one God I love it because it just makes
sense
Islam makes sense is simple it provides
all the evidence and proof that you need
to know that it's indeed from the crater
it's not made up by a man or a group of
men it's indeed from the one who created
mankind and he sent all the guidance to
blueprint how we need to live so we can
be successful in this life and have
eternal paradise in the next the topic
today that we want to discuss is the
judging someone many people when you try
to give them the loving advice and some
people don't give advice obviously the
right way so how can you determine
Sheikh what's the difference between
when someone is judging you and someone
is giving loving advice to you so I
think what's this guy
he sells milkshakes why do we call you
shake I don't know why you called me
shake tell me why you I don't call
myself these are all titles whatever
that I use for respect and scholarship
but back to the question that you asked
you know how do you determine what's
loving advice and judgmental advice well
number one are you giving advice for the
sake of that person's good are you
giving this are you giving advice for
the sake of your own ego many times when
we give advices to make ourselves feel
better not to make the other person feel
better the Arabic word for advice is
nasi ha and mostly huh means to purify
and it actually means to refine
something so the stage of purification
which is the last days of purification
which is refinement so the Arabs used to
say no side to NASA
it's the refinement that I refined the
honey and so the Prophet peace be upon
him he said adenine Ecija the religion
is sincere advice and so what that means
is that no see ha when I give mal see ha
when I give sincere advice my goal
should be to purify that other person
some flaw that they have destructive
quality that they might have are
characteristic to help them out of a
situation that's not good for them so it
should be for the sake of that person if
it's for the sake of that person that
will translate into beautiful words and
it's a good advice and it's a good
speech and hopefully the person
recognizing as well but this is coming
from a good place that this is not
coming you know it's interesting because
the religion is sincere advice and at
the same time Allah strongly in the
Quran strongly condemned ridicule and
mockery ok so which is called Sophia and
Allah said yeah even ladina amanu nyah
scopolamine milk almond ice and yakumo
Heidemann home
what a nice a mini sadness I mean you
couldn't hide a min Han Allah says let
not one of you ridicule another group of
you because they might be better than
you and let not a group of women
ridicule a group of women because they
might be better than them and so the
point is is that if while I'm giving
advice I'm giving advice on the basis
that I am better than you and I'm
telling you that I'm better than you and
I'm and I'm looking down upon you then
I'm not giving you advice
I'm ridiculing you I'm doing something
that's a major sin and
of something that the Prophet peace be
upon him described as the entire
religion which is sincere advice for the
sake of your betterment and bringing you
close to a loss of Hana Hana and making
things easier for you has there ever
been somebody that you sincerely wanted
to give advice to but you know you had
that trepidation now that you're a
little bit worried that you might break
up a relationship or you might mess up a
friendship between you and someone but
you really have this this neat you have
because isn't it
something that is incumbent on Muslims
when you see something bad that you are
to advise that you are to invite to good
forbid evil have you ever been in this
situation absolutely I think all of us
have been in that situation the idea is
that how severe is their situation and
is it better for me to advise through
words or is it better to me for me to
advise through example sometimes leading
by example is much more effective than
words there are some people that are
just not in a position where they can
properly accept advice the Prophet peace
be upon him he said that the worst
people in the sight of Allah are those
that people avoid giving advice to it to
a freshie which means out of fear of
this foul mouth you know there's some
people that have a really bad temper and
if you try to give them advice there's
gonna flip at you so the Prophet peace
be upon him he said that you should that
you should avoid I'm sorry but those are
the worst people those people that are
actually avoided because of their temper
so people just leave them alone and they
essentially let them destroy themselves
so the point is is that again there are
some people that you know you avoid
giving advice to because of their temper
there are some people that you avoid
giving advice to because perhaps you
know it's a minor thing that you want
them to learn on their own you're not at
a point in your relationship yet where
you have that level of trust where they
can look to you and they can really you
know they see you and that advisor
capacity and so you want it you want to
sort of build that relationship a little
bit more I mean that way is advice right
so sometimes you don't give you you give
data through your actions you give that
way through through you know through
through you know you invite to the way
of Allah spend time for your actions
through the way that you live your life
and you carry yourself but at the same
time you're not a point you're not at a
point in your relationship yet where you
can speak to that person and as an
advisor you need to really recognize
when your advice
is counterproductive like the Prophet
Abraham peace be upon him when his
father responded to him with this would
this threat of murder and humiliation
when he just called him with very gentle
words Boheme Abraham peace be upon him
he didn't sit there and continue to
advise him he said peace be on to you I
will seek forgiveness for you okay that
my lord is verily a gracious Lord he's a
compassionate Lord he celebrates my
supplication so Abraham knew peace be
upon him that his father was not in a
position to receive advice anymore we're
gonna take a break they're certainly
gonna have to go to break when we come
back I want you to give me a live
example in your life or a story that you
know that you advise someone turned out
good and maybe something that turned out
bad so we can benefit from a live
experience think about it we'll be right
back with this and more here on the Deen
show it's simple to understand Islam
means submission look at the word
submission not to yourself not to your
desires not to anyone or anything
because the end of the day you get
something you always want more you get
some weed you want more you get some
drugs you want harder drugs you get a
girl you want a nicer girl you get a car
you want a nicer car you get a house on
a nicer house and we've got so many
pressures by enslaving yourself
worshiping God loving God but submission
to the one who created you and by
worshiping going and seeking his
pleasure you get pleased and God bless
you
I am Not Afraid I am not afraid to stand
alone if a box by my side I am not
afraid to stand alone I am not afraid to
stand alone I am Not Afraid
back here on the Dean show with my good
friend Sheikh Omar soon a man okay so
have you thought about a live example
that now you got the courage you got up
and you were like for the love of the
creator I gotta talk to this person
whatever it was or you end up getting
smacked upside your head why something
happen good or bad so we could benefit
or you know someone's relating a story
people like stories they like to you
know live examples look you've got to
understand that you know particularly in
my capacity as a preacher as an imam
I've had many examples of where advice
has gone well and many many times where
advice has not gone tell us please share
with us I have to be very careful okay
you know because I don't want to
sacrifice the trust of any yeah but but
you know just just general I mean I can
I can remember many times where I'll
catch up you know particularly I think
that one of the major issues that we
have with our youth in particular is
obviously dating and relationships and
things of that sort it's like yeah
number in particular you know one
incident where you know I had to stop a
brother that you know was you know
dating and was getting to the point of
committing fornication you know just
outright fornication and things of that
sort and he wasn't heating the religious
warnings and finally when I when I sat
with him and I spoke to him I didn't
necessarily talk about the consequences
in the hereafter I spoke more about the
worldly consequences and so that's one
of the things when you're giving advice
you really want to try to stop that
person from committing the sin by any
means necessary right so I kind of spoke
some about his career his family and
things of that sort then that finally
humbled him to where he could also
receive the advice about the hereafter
as well and you know I look back I'll
give you an example of where the Prophet
peace be upon him said vais went well
and it's in the same it's in the same
situation where I you know a young man
came to the prophet peace be upon when
he told the Prophet peace be upon him
give me a give me permission to commit
fornication I want permission to commit
sin not to commit fornication now the
Prophet peace be upon him he didn't
smack him upside the head he didn't tell
him to go away rather he reasoned with
him
first and foremost his smile peace be
upon him was enough you know and and
talking to the man the young man in a
way that he could properly understand in
his capacity so he tells him you know
would you like someone to fornicate with
your mother mm-hmm and the man said no
he said would you like someone to do
that with your sister he said no he said
what about your aunt he said no so the
Prophet peace be upon him said Cavalia
can us that's how people are - and he
put his hand on his chest and he prayed
for him so the point is is that the
Prophet peace be upon him did not
ridicule him he didn't tell him that
you'll go to hell if you fornicate no
I'm not gonna give you permission to
fornicate rather he came down to his
level he spoke to him on terms that he
could understand now someone might say
I've actually had this situation where
father tells me you know I tried to tell
my son I said would you be okay with
someone dating your mother or committing
adult before an occasion with your
mother he said well if you were dead and
you know a mom you know was dating again
and so he said it totally didn't work it
backfired on him and I told him I said
the point is not necessarily the same
words that the Prophet peace be upon him
used here but rather the approach we
learned from the men hunch from the
methodology of the Prophet peace be upon
him and the methodology was to reason
with him on his level and on his terms
and your body language expresses your
sincerity right expresses your
compassion it expresses it should
express your concern okay so there's a
huge difference between let's take the
same words okay if I said to you would
you be okay with someone committing
fornication with your mother or if I
said to you would you be okay with
someone doing that with your mom you see
it's the same words but the approach the
the way that it was expressed changed
one is with a smile and reasoning and
and really asking a question the other
one is you know is a form of
condemnation it's not really asking a
question it's it's it's condemning the
person the individual so advice should
be certainly to beautify that person to
to make that person better and it should
express your concern and your compassion
to that individual now there's a hadith
and I think it fits in quite well with
this topic where the Prophet peace be
upon him he gave an example of people
being on a ship and if you can take off
with this about you
a certain group of people on the top of
the ship and you had other people on the
bottom of the ship and then from here if
these people didn't come down and give
them that loving advice and then every
the ship ends up sinking no this is a
hadith that snare didn't bow haughty
actually it's a very beautiful hadith
where the Prophet peace be upon him he
described the Ummah he described the
nation as you know the believers as a
group of people on a ship and he says
that the people on the upper deck you
know are the worshippers they're the
religious ones and the people on the
lower deck are the sinners and he said
whenever they need water they don't want
to disturb those that are on the upper
deck so they drill a hole into the
bottom of the ship to get their water
and so the people on the upper deck they
say that they come down and they yell at
them and they say why did you drill a
hole into the bottom of the ship and
they say because you were you were
agitated by our asking you you were
irritated by us and so the Prophet peace
be upon him said that if they let them
do that then the entire ship sinks
otherwise the Prophet peace be upon him
said that the entire ship is safe so the
point is there's so many different
things actually I teach a class called
prophetic musings yeah and some of the
analogies of the Prophet peace be upon
him and I go into quite some depth with
this example there are so many things
number one there's African proverb that
if the youth are not initiated into the
village they will burn it down to feel
its warmth hmm that's a pound a lot
there are a lot of times where you see
that there are people that are away from
Allah away from Islam but no one's
reaching out to them so there's a
disconnect between the religious class
and the not so religious class there's
grouping and so the messages even the
mosque becomes a clinic that doesn't
accept sick people you know people have
issues in their lives don't go to the
Masjid nor they've made to feel welcome
in the messages in the mosque because
they're not dressed properly they're not
worshipping properly they don't know how
to pray we know what's really going on
in your life the mustard is supposed to
be for everyone so the religious class
is supposed to go out to those that are
falling and faltering and give them
advice lovingly
and not make them feel like they're
there they're irritating them you know I
was reading a study from the Pew
Research Center about churches in
America they were saying that young
people are turned off by the church
because they feel intimidated by the
elderly for example there's a sense of
intimidation so that intimidation factor
has to be removed and that can be
removed from loving advice and you know
and in fact one of the other meanings of
MIL seha is to bond it brings people
together and so sometimes that time when
you sit down your brother and you and
you talk to him in a loving way and you
give him advice it's not about the issue
at hand anymore
he now trusts you he loves you he
appreciates the way that you came to him
and so unless he how actually brings
people together and so that's what the
Prophet peace be upon him is teaching us
that when you see something on Facebook
or see something on YouTube or see
something on Twitter or hear about
something you know with someone that you
know you should give them the dignity of
sitting with them and saying look I love
you I care about you if you need
anything let me know if there's a reason
why you've resorted to the sin because a
lot of times we just can't we just
condemn without asking why perhaps what
led to the sin now why did the people
drill the hole in the ship because they
were thirsty so why do people commit sin
because there was something missing in
their lives so perhaps someone committed
you know a sin because there were family
issues so the point is is that I need to
also part of my giving advices is sowing
concerned is everything okay
why did you resort to that in the first
place how can I help you
how can I be there for you and inshallah
ty will tell you a story inshaallah as
well that i just thought of afterwards
and so we got the story ready okay I'm
gonna take a break and then we're going
to come back with more and wrap it up
here with sheikh omar suleiman give me
that loving advice we right back on adi
show
or it can't have defects in it can it if
it is literally God's Word yes it cannot
have defects I mean this was written by
men you know that this is a collection
right even if you have Matthew Mark Luke
and John the Gospel according to
according to right the thing about the
Quran and the biggest and you know I'll
leave you with this is the biggest thing
for me is if the Quran is exactly what
it says it is and this doesn't matter
whether you're Muslim or not if the
Quran is what it says it is the Quran is
literally the Word of God
delivered via Gabriel to Muhammad who
was an unlettered man who couldn't read
or write right and he was just told to
recite right that was the first thing
right first thing is to recite right so
if it is literally the Word of God then
that's pretty important to me and before
I became Muslim I said if this is the
Word of God then I'm gonna follow it
because I'd be stupid not to back here
on the Deen show and we're talking about
the right way to give advice and the and
the right way in the wrong way and then
you had a story before he went to break
please share with us so this was a story
actually someone that took Shahada with
me he became Muslim Whitney you know in
college and you know for a few years he
disappeared from the mustard scene he
disappeared from the mosque he really
wasn't involved in the religion anymore
and he calls me out of the blue three
four years later and I pick up the phone
and I was so shocked that it was him and
you know he's going off on a some going
off on Allah going off on the Prophet
peace be upon him just saying
blasphemous things and he's trying to
start an argument and I wasn't
responding to him okay so I was being
quiet and you know at the end basically
where he ranted on the religion and
things of that sort you know I told him
I said well you know I'm sorry that you
feel that way and to each his own you
know I I certainly don't agree with some
of the things that you said and you know
hopefully one day we can get together
it's been a long time since we've seen
each other anyway hopefully one day we
can get together and we can kind of
discuss these issues again it was like
wait that's it he was he was surprised
that I didn't go off on him so I was
like yeah I was like you know you're in
I don't care to your views but you know
I miss you man I haven't seen you for a
long time so when are we gonna get
together and maybe we can discuss this
over lunch so then he just broke down
crying and so I realized that there was
something deeper than that and so he
starts to tell me about some things that
were going on with his family and he
starts to tell me about some things
going on in his life some personal
issues and I helped him with that and
then next thing you know he's back at
Jamaat
he's back in this lab so his issue was
never theological in the first place it
was a cry for help it was a cry for
attention and so sometimes we have to
understand that people that sin people
that mess up online people that post
outrageous photos or start saying
certain things it's really a cry for
help
and as a brother as a sister just as I
be concerned for my sibling I wouldn't
just want to correct them with the sin
I'd want to make sure that I help them
and that I'm there for them might be
concerned about their mental health
their spirituality so on and so forth I
should afford that same thing to my
brother and sister in faith let's go to
the flipside for the person getting the
advice too so we know that you giving
the advice you should go out of your way
to be loving and kind giving loving
advice but let's say you've gotten some
advice you've gotten in 1020 times and
maybe you didn't get it you know
sugar-coated the way you'd like with
roses and candy and all that how should
you also because we know that the
creator tells us that advice benefits
the believer right so and then there's a
flip side to it it increased so judge me
yeah don't judge me so now should you
also be even if you didn't get those
roses with the advice it's come to you
can can this sometimes be a sign that
you have to reflect to that there might
be some truth in some of these things
that people been trying to advise you
look of the love and masud may allah be
pleased with him one of the great
companions of the Prophet peace be upon
him he said the most hated words to
Allah are don't judge me when someone
gives you advice and you say don't judge
me so you know if you read the books of
spirituality and tusky on Islam and
things of that sort and you read the
lives of the Companions one of the
things that's consistent is consider
advice even from your enemies consider
what people say about you even if it's
your enemies that's deep
why because perhaps there might be some
truth to what he's saying and a great
scholar by the name of Ananda bin Kodama
may Allah be pleased with him he said if
I had a scorpion on my back about to
bite me I would expect someone who
pointed out to me so he said you know so
he said you know a spiritual disease is
far greater than you know that than a
scorpion which is which is going to
cause physical harm so that which would
cause me spiritual harm is greater to me
so I would certainly want someone to
point that out to me as well so if
someone points it something out to me or
gives me advice in a very rude manner
quite frankly with personal insults and
just in a disgusting way then I'm going
to ignore the disgust I'm going to
ignore the personal insults but I'm
going to say hey there might be a
scorpion on me I'm not gonna say well I
don't like the way you told me about
that scorpion I'm gonna go ahead and let
it bite me mm-hmm right so there's a
story that I always tell it's a story
from the great Imam Imam - a fairy he's
one of the 40 moms of the Orthodox Islam
the Sunni school of thought and he and
he was once sitting down and he was a
great email giving lectures and the
measures of the Prophet peace be upon
him in fact only a few years after the
Prophet peace be upon him died a hundred
years or so after the Prophet peace be
upon him passed away he's giving
lectures in the mosque great Imam
someone walks him to him and says are
you a Shaffer he said yeah I'm a Shaffer
day he said in Natchitoches Ian facet
you are an evil wicked men now the
students of the amount of Schaffer he
wanted to jump this man he managed a
ferry he raised his hands and he
supplicated he made dua he said along
encounter sladek on Oh a lot if he's
telling the truth
[ __ ] literally what honey what about you
then forgive me and have mercy upon me
and accept my repentance
what in Cana later Datuk and if he's not
telling the truth he didn't say well
encounter CAD even if he's a liar he
didn't resort he didn't go sink to that
man's level he said if he's not telling
the truth
forgive him Buffalo or Hamoui tomaría
forgive him and have mercy on him and
accept his repentance and so the beauty
of that is that look in life you will
always have imbalanced praise and you
will always have imbalance criticism I'm
a public figure on my facebook page
right or my Twitter you'll have people
that will say you're so awesome
mashallah greatest man in the world then
you'll have so imbalance praise it's
it's it's I have to be able to ignore
that and at the same time you know I get
300 400 emails a day
of people criticizing not criticizing
things legit but but sometimes mocking
me my appearance my words slandering me
my family right I've had people say
nasty things about my mother
right who's passed away may Allah have
mercy on her people that try to poke at
you and so one of the things that my
teacher said he said look you're always
gonna have cheerleaders and haters
imbalanced praise and in bounce
criticism what you need to do is you
need to be able to reduce that to noise
so that you can recognize balanced
praise which is encouragement so that
shows you what you're doing well and at
the same time balanced criticism so that
you don't lose yourself in the process
of doing that good and if it's even good
in the first place so it doesn't matter
who's saying what to me he might be
telling the truth right and that was
that there was the sincerity of him a
mushaf read that you know that person
might be telling me the truth even if I
don't like the way that he said and
people don't like the way that he said
it so when someone gives you advice and
and someone criticizes you and hates on
you ignore the hatred ignore that but
don't be someone who meets a loss of
contact with that very characteristic in
that very sin that was pointed out to
you just because of the way that it was
said to you
that's deep it's balanced I love it it's
balanced now give some loving advice
there's a lot of people there holding on
to the deen by a thread may Allah
protect us from that's a scary thing so
now you have the opportunity to reach
out we only got a minute left and give
some loving advice to those who are
struggling everyone is struggling with
their faith in some way and the Prophet
peace be upon him did not teach us Islam
as a faith to us is not being on a
constant spiritual high it's that even
whenever you're going through your low
moments and you're going through your
your moments of discouragement and
disappointment you never completely lose
faith and so a lot of times you know
we're made to feel like low iman low
faith is is just like no iman no faith
whereas sometimes you know your iman
your faith might feel low you might be
going through something in life just
don't lose faith altogether don't sit
don't sink your own ship don't despair
as the devil despaired always have that
balance of fear and hope and always make
sure that you're progressing even
whenever you're you're feeling low that
you're that you're making amends in the
progressing towards allah and don't lose
hope everyone goes through their low
points beautiful we have to go but
hadith it says tolerable in me Farida
tune Allah Allah Muslims a house it goes
yes that seeking knowledge is a comment
on every Muslim and Muslims once mr.
rule of God the fuel for that car is
that gas fuel for the Iman is knowledge
where can people go in flips I heard you
got some really great stuff there tell
us about it
so how many I want you know I I left
Imam I kind of retired early from being
any mom just so I could focus on on
knowledge my passion is studying and
teaching so I have some you know videos
on YouTube with Quran weekly and I've
got some University you know some
institutes that I teach with Michigan
University bayyinah and method of
Institute I have classes with them and
my own project my own personal project
is and flicks comm ILM FLI XCOM hundreds
and hundreds of hours of Islamic
lectures very unorthodox in regards to
the topics that are being addressed
so we're addressing topics that are so
we have some tough see it and things of
the sort explanation of the Quran and at
the same time we have some topics like
fifth of pregnancy you know black
companions of the Prophet peace be upon
him how the Prophet fought racism
practical things you can do with your
life so it's hundreds of hours it's all
for free in sha Allah all you have to do
is go online and register at and flexkom
ILM FLI XCOM and you get a whole library
and live classes and shout law as well
does that go fight oh thank you all very
much oh yeah thank you very much so
Michael sighs well thank you thank you
for being with us thank you and there
you have it so much love to give
that's right and how are you gonna get
the love if you don't open your mind in
your heart to so much love to give so
much loving advice and now you've gotten
it here some great advice what are you
gonna do with it if somebody's been
trying to deliver something to you like
we've been trying to deliver the truth
that there's only one God that you
worship Him alone not his creation and
you have all of everything that he's
sent through this last and final mission
or problem Hamid peace be upon him is
encapsulated in Islam and the loving
advice that we've given you and we're
giving you is to look into Islam
call us at
so we hope to see you back here again
next week on the Dean show follow us on
the Twitter like us on the Facebook
where you can keep up with all of our
shows help share this message because if
you love if you care you share so make
sure you share and we'll see you next
time
god-willing in sha allah until then
peace be with you